las traslaciones reflexiones en las
gráficas nos ayudan a realizar el
movimiento o desplazamiento de una
función en un plano de coordenadas ya
sea hacia arriba hacia abajo a la
izquierda oa la derecha
vamos a conocer la traslación de una
función a su inversa que se da sobre los
ejes x
así que tomaremos como ejemplo a la
función de x cúbica cuya gráfica se ve
así recuerda que cualquier función de
este tipo siempre tendrá el mismo
comportamiento
si tenemos que fx es igual a equis
cúbica para encontrar su inversa vamos a
despejar x como tiene el exponente 3 al
pasarlo del otro lado queda como la raíz
cúbica de ye despejamos nuevamente y y
nos queda que fx es igual a la raíz
cúbica de x la gráfica que la
representaría sería la siguiente
comparemos ambas gráficas para observar
los cambios ya viste si la sobre ponemos
en el mismo plano
podemos apreciar con más claridad cómo
sería la transformación de esta función
ya que la obtener su inversa cambio
justo como si la viéramos a través de un
espejo para practicar te invita a que
reconozcas y dibujes en tu cuaderno la
función inversa de ye igual a equis
cuadrada más 2